alors focus people Benoît Magimel Julie
Gayet encore elle décidément
comprenez-vous ces stars qui souhaitent
garder leur vie privée qui refusent de
toute interview c'est l'acteur Benoît
Magimel qui est revenu sur son rapport
aux journalistes à la presse people il a
déclaré de jeunes pour France Inter être
le cauchemar des journalistes regardez
[Musique]
les pistes je veux pas qu'on en apprenne
trop sur moi parce que je veux qu'on
puisse plaquer tout ce qu'on peut
vouloir plaquer ne pas en dire trop sur
vous ça veut dire là on va passer un
moment ensemble ça veut dire ne pas trop
livrer en interview donc par exemple non
maintenant je parle beaucoup plus
facilement parce que j'ai fait un tour
de piste quand même mais c'est vrai que
j'étais catalogué cauchemars des
journalistes princes du silence quoi
parce qu'à chaque fois on posait des
questions
[Applaudissements]
Vincent Cassel dit la même chose
il dit question que voilà ça vous
regarde pas c'est très curieux faire de
la promotion cette année merci c'est un
langage à maîtriser je suis admiratif
des gens qui le font moi j'aime pas
faire ça le plus discret
au cinéma lui demande pas d'être bon en
interview le problème
il a travaillé
du grand public tu dois te livrer un
petit peu quand même c'est
donnant-donnants
de cinéma il y a marqué que tu te dois
de faire la promo mais faire la promo ça
veut pas dire
ça te dit pas quel âge a ton fils avec
qui tu couches mais il n'y a rien de
plus insupportable qu'avoir un mec en
promo qui est là assis sur son siège qui
veut rien dire qu'il tire la tronche et
qui est comme ça
c'est une personnalité publique on veut
savoir tu vois c'est différent quand
même tout d'un coup ouais ouais ouais
ouais ouais ouais je vais répondre à
Benoît parce qu'il a dit un truc qui est
faux
qui n'est pas ton avis aujourd'hui je
pense en tout cas que c'est faux ce
n'est pas mon avis parce que la
popularité aujourd'hui d'une célébrité
est un dissociable des salibuer moi je
ne parle pas de oui un minimum pourquoi
parce que la plupart des célébrités
aujourd'hui tu as besoin de les admirer
tu vas pas juste les voir au cinéma ou
acheter leur album parce que tu aimes
leurs produits aujourd'hui c'est les
réseaux sociaux qu'on fait ça c'est la
télé pendant pendant des décennies
aujourd'hui pourquoi tu mets un poster
d'une star dans ta chambre c'est pas
juste parce que c'est un bon acteur
c'est aussi parce que c'est quelqu'un
que tu te rends Florent bébé comment tu
peux dire une telle bêtise c'est la
vérité mais non mais non une star c'est
comme le sexe c'est
si c'est 50% du plaisir
il faut jamais rencontrer ses idoles au
contraire pourquoi jenny est une star tu
sais pas où il habite tu sais pas quoi
il vit tu sais pas ce qu'elle mange tu
sais rien c'est avec Jean-Michel Jarre
elle a eu plein de polémiques sur le
dossier
Mylène Farmer Océane et c'est tout et
pas oui mais il y a eu plein de rumeurs
il y a eu plein de choses qu'elle a un
peu alimenté aussi et juste une dernière
chose il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
célébrités et ça c'est très important et
je l'avais déjà dit qui s'arrange aussi
avec ça c'est-à-dire qu'elle communique
pas quand elles ont pas envie puis tout
d'un coup ah bah tiens je vais faire un
petit tapis rouge avec mon compagnon
avec ma compagne parce qu'à ce moment-là
ça m'arrange il y a aussi
tu te fais un film de quelqu'un moi
Benoît Magimel je trouve beau je l'aime
bouquet beaucoup bah si tout d'un coup
tu sais quoi c'était pendant le covid
j'adore j'adore le chanteur Raphaël bah
je reconnais quand je l'ai vu chanter
dans sa cuisine assis sur un chiotte
avec ça avec sa femme qui passe derrière
bah tout d'un coup il s'était monsieur
tout le monde et je veux pas payer ma
place pour aller voir Monsieur tout le
monde tu parles des énormes stars sauf
que là ce qui est un peu focus c'est
deux mauvaises exemples elle veut pas
d'interview parce qu'on le parle tout le
temps de François Hollande et ben j'y
mail il a tellement de casserole des
problèmes de drogue cache pas qu'on lui
parle c'est alors vous en êtes où avec
vos problèmes de drogue donc c'est une
journaliste
plutôt que ça ramène toi ça c'est pour
ça c'est un cas particulier maintenant
c'est une cote mal taillée évidemment
qui veulent pas tout dire et nous on
leur pose quand même quelques questions
qui vont au-delà de la promotion et
après c'est une question de de
d'affinités jusqu'au on peut aller trop
loin jusqu'où ils peuvent parler mais en
revanche c'est odieux c'est quelqu'un
qui accepte pour la promotion et qui ne
dit rien avec une comédienne au bout de
5 minutes je lui ai dit ça vous fait
chier non mais je suis désolé
si tu connais c'est une star c'est
monsieur tout le monde non c'est à la
même vie que monsieur tout le monde
c'est quoi la différence
quand vous interviews dedans il vous
disait des choses
un jour j'ai rencontré quelqu'un dans la
rue qui me dit oh là là à la télé et
vous avez pas de patron c'est super puis
j'imagine que ce soit tous les soirs
quand tu rentres tu dois les soirées
Christian Dior avec des mannequins ça
doit rigoler champagne mais tu as une
vidéo ouf j'ai dit bah ouais ouais c'est
pas faux
chauffeur qui m'attend la vérité c'était
quoi j'ai une Smart qui est garée qui
est dégueulasse je rentre chez moi je
mets un jogging je mets dans le job dans
un top power du poulet et des légumes je
dîne ça tout seul chez moi et je me
couche waouh
ben non si les gens savaient ça tout
d'un coup pour une star tu te dis c'est
triste la réponse
la réponse est peut-être dans la
question qu'on l'a posé c'est est-ce que
vous comprenez que certains people ne
veulent pas et moi je dis oui de chacun
Goldman il a fait tout sa carrière sans
raconter sa vie privée avoir donc vous
n'avez pas beaucoup vu ou même voir très
peu vu mes enfants et j'en ai
quelques-uns dans les gala Les machins
et cetera de savoir combien
Goldman Farmer Vanessa Paradis Beyoncé
Bradley Cooper ces gens-là c'est des
noms on sait pas très bien aux habits on
sait pas très bien ce qu'ils font du
coup il y a beaucoup de rumeurs sur eux
du coup comme des rumeurs on se fait des
films et là tu parles des immenses
de qui toi
Madonna c'est pas voilà donc Julie Gayet
on répond à ta question donc on a une
petite star pour répondre aux questions
débiles des journalistes
de célébrités
quand elle dit qu'elle veut pas qu'on
lui pose des questions mais que encore
cette semaine elle répond et qu'elle
revient sur l'histoire de de Closer qui
avait publié les photos avec François
Hollande et qu'elle fait un petit laïus
d'une minute où elle dit à l'époque
j'avais une copine qui se faisait passer
pour moi pour éviter les photographes
elle en parle donc voilà moi ce que je
te c'est qu'ils en parlent quand ça les
arrange là elle est en promo
du métier parler éventuellement des
médias etc et montrer ta vie privée
montrer tes gosses par exemple il y a
des stars qui montre facilement moi je
me souviens à l'époque souvenez-vous le
grand parc avec Mickey qui est à côté de
Paris invité tous les gens qui faisaient
la télé photo les enfants les petits les
grands les moyens et cetera tout le
monde y aller pardon tu peux choisir d'y
aller ou pas d'y aller en clair d'être
invité parce que tu es rincé
Isabelle sera gentil ça va dans ton sens
mais voilà point barre ça dépend de la
mentalité que tu as quoi tu fais ce
métier je fais de la télé du cinéma tu
es pas obligé de faire participer la
famille j'aimerais bien je préviens
quand même juste une seconde la
production qu'est-ce qui est quand même
très important comme je vois que la
publie dans un petit moment qu'en
revanche je n'ai plus de fiche pour la
suite pardon
tu vas encore saboter mon ami 3 semaines
de suite hein
qui posent des questions complètement
con et toujours les mêmes je vais vous
expliquer ce que c'est parce que moi
j'ai déjà vécu à mon petit niveau c'est
pas du journaliste vous cherchez la la
vous là les ronds de cuir vous cherchez
la petite phrase pour la mettre en une
alors vous allez dire par exemple je
trouve que Nagui a beaucoup de talents
mais je n'aime pas Nagui Mathieu
Delormeau 2 points je n'aime pas c'est
ce que vous faites aujourd'hui
alors du coup on vous parle plus parce
que c'est ça vous cherchez la petite
phrase vous n'écoutez rien mais dans la
presse écrite qui fait le titre n'est
pas le journaliste
vous cherchez du buzz négatif
est-ce que je peux répondre à Laurent
oui Laurent l'année dernière je l'ai
interviewé pour closer on a fait une
interview qui était très sympa on a
parlé du retour de la vérité qui compte
d'accord et à la fin je vais poser une
petite question perso sur lui sa famille
ses enfants une petite réponse hyper
sympa qui rajoute un peu de sel un peu
de piment à l'interview et voilà la
question je demandais bah voilà s'il
avait des petites coutumes avec ses
enfants quand est-ce qu'il se
retrouvaient etc mercredi soir je disais
avec exactement et leur conjoint et
c'était une petite anecdote qui est que
je ne ferai jamais rien d'autre mercredi
soir que vous faites et ben c'était
super intéressant il peut s'identifier à
ça merci merci
et du coup c'était quoi le titre vas-y
dis-moi le titre vas-y vas-y je me
rappelle
le retour du rideau Laurent délaisse ses
enfants six jours sur ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vrai que tu peux répondre à tous
les sujets sans mettre sans exposer les
gens
et que vous êtes choqués je peux le
comprendre et présentera ses excuses
mais c'est vrai que Laurent passe pas
beaucoup de temps avec ses enfants ils
disent pas souvent avec il les voit pas
beaucoup de sa carrière et c'est pas
joli joli tout ça il va avoir un hashtag
la prunelle de mes yeux Laurent